elle n'en a été propriétaire que trois
ans mais a laissé son nom
madame du barry la dernière favorite du
roi louis 15 pour ces journées du
patrimoine le siège de la cci versailles
yvelines dévoile ses secrets historiques
et curiosités comme ce mangeur de
spaghetti avec les doigts les curiosités
du grand tour c'était quand les gens
allaient à naples il était quand même
assez assez surpris de voir ces gens
manger des pâtes dans la rue donc c'est
ce que l'on peut voir ce personnage de
la commedia dell arte qui mange ses
maccarone et comme on disait à l'époque
avec les doigts devenu bâtiments
militaires sous la révolution le site
est le siège de la chambre de commerce
depuis 1937 sous le regard des visiteurs
tableau et boiseries d'époque on connaît
mal ce bâtiment effectivement on est à
peu attiré par la façade puis le
histoire que qui se cache derrière ces
murs c'est surtout l'architecturé de ces
salles qui sont pratiquement d'origine
fâcheux tir haut niveau et des plantes
du tracé et puis des boiseries qui sont
superbes
c'est d'avoir le jardin qui a excité la
curiosité parce que habitant la maison
d'à côté et j'ai une vue plongeante sur
ce grand jardin
le bâtiment je connaissais déjà un petit
peu la maison parce que j'ai assisté à
des conférences qui s'y tiennent
régulièrement
l'hôtel a connu une histoire mouvementée
une petite histoire au coeur de la
grande mise en parallèle pour l'occasion
avec la nouvelle bd de thierry laudrin
présents ce jour là pour une dédicace ou
versailles a bien sûr une grande place